I think everyone had this moment in
Elden ring you find a building hidden in
the forest of lim Graves Mistwood and
the door mysteriously opens of its own
volition to reveal an elevator down that
just keeps going and going on and on
until you forget that you're even
Underground
cavernous roof is now so far above that
it might as well be a false night sky
and the world below has life light and a
culture of its own
what's interesting about the environment
down here is that it's actually a fusion
of cultures there are the dynastic
remains infested with claymen and then
there's the ancestral grounds brimming
with wildlife but built amidst it all
between the ruins Beyond The ancestral
grounds and even hanging from the
ceilings are the incredible Eternal
cities inhabited by the Knox
for now think of the Knox as just these
enemies the monks swordstresses and
night maidens of the Eternal cities the
word Knox means night in Latin some of
you might remember this from the phrase
vario knocks in Dark Souls which was
commonly held to mean fear the night
this theme has carried over to Eldon
ring where fear and respect for the
night is conveyed by characters like
Rani who seek to usher in an age of
stars here begin it's a chill night that
encompasses all
reaching the great beyond
into fear
and loneliness
and just like the age of dark in Dark
Souls the coming age of stars is
presented as a bit of an inevitability
in Elden ring or at least it might have
been were it not for starskoge radan who
locked the stars out of motion and
fettered the Fate once written in the
night sky on behalf of the golden order
again this is just like in Dark Souls
where the coming age of dark was stolen
from mankind by a greater power yet even
now the age of stars continues to be
championed by a people called the Knox
except now the knocks have been banished
to the underground and here they live in
this state of
Eternal anticipation just endlessly
waiting for a fate that has been taken
away from them
whenever explicitly told which act it
was that led to the nox's banishment but
my best guess is that it has to do with
this the Finger Slayer blade which we
loot beneath the Giant's throne in
nocron a part of its description reads
this blood-drenched fetish is proof of
the high treason committed by the
Eternal City and symbolizes its downfall
so what was the nature of the nox's high
treason then well this is a Finger
Slayer blade one that is able to harm
the greater will and its vassals this
blade is drenched in Blood and proof of
high treason so it seems like the weapon
was successfully used but we can only
really speculate on which pair of two
fingers this blade might have been used
on of course it might have just been
high treason to create this blade in the
first place and this weapon is said to
be born of a corpse so let's take a
closer look at its icon doing so reveals
a spine running up the blade and two
arms that form the hilt so clearly this
weapon is born of a corpse but it's not
the only weapon in game that's like this
remember that moment at the end of the
game where the Elden Beast reaches into
the ground and pulls a sword from
radigan's Corpse that is the sacred
Relic sword and it's 2 is a spined
spiral Blade with a human forming the
hilt so to sum in this item's
description this weapon represents the
end of an age and to others the
beginning
now I kind of doubt that the Finger
Slayer blade is made from a corpse
that's as powerful as Radigan just
because it seems so much smaller broken
and Limp but regardless it clearly was
an attempt to bring about the end of one
age and the beginning of another just so
the Finger Slayer blade can only be
wielded by Ronnie who needs the weapon
to claim her fate and achieve her ending
but this can only happen when you defeat
radan and unlock the Fate in the night
sky because doing so sets free a star
from the cosmos which crashes into Lim
grave revealing the path to nocoron the
Eternal City where the Finger Slayer
blade lies hidden
there are multiple Eternal cities that
are spread widely across the lands
between and located deep beneath the
Earth
first we have the city of nocron that
Lies Beneath lingrave the entrance to
this city is torn open by redan's
meteorite when we explore it so all of
the foremost buildings are ruined but
they form the path leading to this
undisturbed multi-layered city that's
sort of tucked behind the dynastic
remains and the ancestral environs that
were built here long before
then there's no Cron's twin the city of
Knox Stella which is located beneath
Leonia I think most people would have
got their first hint of this city when
they wound up in the Ansel River
Fighting the Dragon Kin soldier of
noxtella but the true city is further up
from here stretching out between long
sections of ant infested tunnels here
the Knox have actually learned how to
ride these ants though the ants will
happily turn on them if given the chance
but there's a third City a completely
devastated nameless City located beneath
Lane Del which is a place we'll have to
talk about a little bit later in this
video
these three cities just have incredible
architecture I love knockron's massive
inverted towers and it's cool how knock
Stella's shining city is built right
into this low-hanging false night sky
and now the game isn't really clear on
whether these cities existed before the
nox's banishment underground or if they
were built afterwards however I'm
inclined to think that they actually
existed before their banishment take the
fingerslayer blades description for
instance this weapon is the most likely
reason for the noxus banishment and it
lays the high treason at the feet of the
Eternal City it doesn't blame the Knox
who would have existed above ground at
some point it blames the Eternal City
but regardless while they at least might
have already had these well-developed
cities down here their banishment was
still a brutal punishment because the
knocks would have been cut off from the
true night sky which was a core part of
their culture as some small Comfort I
speculate that they created these false
night skies which are made of suspended
white fragments this they accept as they
wait for the age of stars to begin
in order to learn more about these
cities though I'd like to look at some
data mind information of course you have
to take this with a grain of salt but in
version 1.0 of Elden ring the Eternal
City buildings are frequently listed as
America's ruins and the Eternal City
Pavilions are America's Pavilions what's
more the Knox themselves are actually
called America's descendants this
obviously has pretty huge implications
so let's try to break down America's
ancestry and see if we can arrive at the
Knox
so America herself is of the Newman Race
who according to the character Creations
screen are supposed descendants of
denizens of another world
the only other supposed Newman in game
are the black knife assassins who
according to their silver armor were all
women and rumored to be Newman who had
close ties with America herself and we
have proof that these Newman black
knives were tied to the Eternal cities
they say the Assassins who carried out
the deed were signs of the Eternal City
so if we take Roger at his word then it
seems like Newman are indeed tied up
with the genealogy of the Eternal City
and that America herself is likely one
of the knox's ancestors you could go as
far as to say that America is actually
from an eternal City too she is called
the Eternal after all but again remember
this is data mind information that we're
not really supposed to know but at any
rate while the nox might be descended
from the Newman I think enough time has
passed that most knocks aren't really
considered Newman anymore if anything
they're now more akin to the night folk
which is actually another descendancy
you can choose for your tarnished in the
Character Creator night folk and Knox
share similarly huge skin and night folk
are a race that was said to bleed silver
long ago
so let's finally actually talk about the
Knox monks the priestesses the night
maidens and the silver that they wield
the monks of the Eternal cities are all
men and they fight with flowing weapons
of liquid metal so too do the
swordstresses a female cast of the Knox
who are agile Warriors and serve as the
personal guards of the night maidens the
night maidens themselves are said to be
of the highest clerical Rank and it's
definitely interesting that a group of
Maidens would be of the highest clerical
rank it's almost as if the night maidens
exist as a sort of parallel to the
kindling maidens of the two fingers who
serve the tarnished so that they might
become Lord because remember a core part
of the Knox culture is also about
searching for a lord to serve except
unlike the title Elden Lord The Knocks
are waiting for a lord of night in a way
this Lord of night is almost an
imitation of the olden Lord which would
make sense because the knocks are
extremely well versed in the art of
imitation so let's talk about that I
think I speak for a lot of us here when
I say that a core part of so many of our
late game playthroughs were the mimic
tier Spirit ashes which copied the form
of their Summoner and from a law point
of view the whole point of this mimic
tier is actually to mimic the tarnished
who might become the Elden Lord its
description reads mimic tears are a
result of an attempt by the Eternal City
to forge a lord however the description
also says that their mimicry does not
extend to imitating the summoner's will
this makes it seem like mimic tears are
this tool right they're something to be
used to achieve the Eternal cities ends
so it's important to point out here that
mimic tears are actually more accurately
silver tears and silver tears literally
are tools because they're wielded by The
Knocks As Weapons The Knocks flowing
hammer and the knox-flowing sword are
forged from the liquid metal of silver
tears and tempered to hardness this
gives them the ability to extend Bend
and when wielded by The Knocks to
drastically change their form into
spiked Shields and even giant hands and
what's kind of chilling to realize is
that these weapons are actually living
beings
this is all quite clearly inspired by
ancient alchemical conceptions of
mercury or Quicksilver which was this
compound that was believed to be able to
shift between liquid and solid States as
well as life and death in game silver
tears are called formless life able to
be reborn again and again into imitation
they are as much a substance as they are
a living organism and we see this in
their multitude of forms silver spheres
trolls and even night folk to name but a
few
there's even this entire cut quest line
that would have had you bond with a
silver mimic tear called asimi In The
Cut dialog files this mimic tear claims
to have grown a desire for life and
knowledge and lordship and she desires
to share the throne with you
you could have become Eldon Lord
and I could have become sovereign
eternal
I think and I know a lot of you guys did
as well when I mentioned this last time
I think this would have gone a really
long way towards making players relate
to the story of the Knox and it would
have made them question the order of the
earth tree even more and after learning
about this questline I can definitely
see why mimic tears and artificial life
might have been this enormous threat to
the Earth trees Authority The Knocks
were after all messing with these
crucial things that the old tree had
come to govern they were messing with
the powers of Life Death and Rebirth of
course we know that death was sacrosanct
to the urge tree during its age as I
discussed in my video on death many
ancient methods of death came to be
abandoned or shunned in favor of
returning to the Earth trees Roots
instead through the process of a tree
burial all the old ways of death were
abandoned and as for rebirth while the
Earth tree is never really explicitly
said to be able to to rebirth beings I
think a lot of people just assume that
it's implied but there is a bit of
evidence many depictions of the old tree
actually show human forms growing along
its branches just as they show human
forms being absorbed in death by its
roots
and you can't forget that an entire
great Rune of the Elden ring explicitly
governs rebirth this is Ronaldo's Amber
egg and inside it is the great Rune of
The Unborn
in the end lady Ronaldo was left to
learn
cradling the Amber egg Lord radican
bequeathed her now she devotes herself
to it through forbidden right the Grim
art of reincarnation
I think Muriel calls Ronaldo's
reincarnation a grim act here because
reincarnation already has a bit of a
history with the knocks in the lands
between and ranala isn't the Earth tree
so I can see how what she's doing might
be a bit sacrilegious she's even capable
of using larval tears from the Eternal
City so Muriel speaking as any follower
of the earth tree would understandably
the cries ranala's rebirths as forbidden
rights and when I searched for this
phrase forbidden writes in my dialogue
spreadsheet I stumbled upon cut dialogue
from thops who confirms that forbidden
rights like this did indeed originate in
the Eternal City I don't think it's a
coincidence that forbidden rights is the
same phrase used for ranala and by
thoughts as well oh one more thing
beware the albinotics
cursed Souls born of a forbidden right
of the Eternal City
[Music]
so the albinorex albanorics seemed to be
a reference to the ancient Notions of
artificial life and that's something
that's supported by the albenoric blood
clot description which calls them life
forms made by human hands according to
the albinorex shield albanorex is said
to have been created from a primordial
drop of dew which to me evokes the old
tree's own imagery of Jew where drops of
Life dripped from the herd trees
branches a sort of imitation in that way
to me the Ripple blade that is wielded
by Young albinorex Echoes this stating
that ripples are thought to be at the
origin of their species obviously these
are all references to liquid and it
suggests that albinorex are born of the
same liquid silver that we just
discussed an older description of the
blue silver set also confirms this
calling albionics children of silver and
there are a few different types of
albinoric that can be encountered game
they're a first generation albanorics
who have withered legs and are called
The albanorics Vault and then they're a
second generation albanorics who
resemble frogs and are called the Young
albanorics
let's discuss these first generation
Albion oryx first as far as enemy models
go there are the men who are commonly
the subject of torture and genocide and
then there are the women who seem to
have learned to defend themselves as
albinoric wolf back archers this is
probably a good time to mention this
isn't the only example in this video
where the women of the culture are far
more dexterous than the men all of the
black knives are women the Knox
swordstresses defend the night maidens
who are of the highest rank and if we're
talking about rank then karia and its
princesses as well are a prime example
of that speaking of karia actually pedia
is an example of an albinoric man that
serves karya and other albenoric men in
Korea have clearly learned glenstone's
sorcery not to mention Loretta but maybe
that's the story for another time
moving on to the second generation
albanorics as Nua albanorics and
alliance between the formula for these
artificial humans seems to have been
improved as they now have legs which
they put to comically good use although
thops in his cut dialogue does say that
they've lost the use of their tongues so
they really haven't got the formula
quite right there's something also going
on with their heads which from software
themselves call Dumpy and frog-like you
can even loot The albenoric Mask which
is literally just their own face skinned
in an active malicious mockery and I
really shouldn't laugh but it is kind of
funny admittedly that even Elden ring
players are also guilty of genociding
helpless albanorics there's this site in
Morgan Palace where it's just Far and
Away the best way to farm runes and
thousands of players just kill these
albinorex over and over again
it's just the perfect example of
gameplay matching lore anyway with all
of this terrible [ __ ] happening to album
oryx frankly just for the sheer audacity
of them simply existing it's no surprise
that they see mikola's halik tree as a
Haven but in talking about that we're
getting far away from the Eternal cities
so let's get back to there so it appears
the Eternal cities weren't content with
just birthing silver tears and
albanorics because the dragonkin too
were born in the Eternal City there are
a tragic view that you can fight down
there and unlike the real stone dragons
up above they knew no true sky nor true
lightning it seems these dragonkin were
created I think with the intent of
achieving a sort of immortality
something that is suggested by the
dragon scale blade which is an ice
lightning weapon that reads a weapon
made by sharpening a gravel Stone scale
thought to be the source of Dragon
immortality into an unclouded blade alas
The Dragon King soldiers never attained
immortality and perished as decrepit
pale imitations of their skyborne kin
there's the word imitation again and
interestingly just like the finguslayer
blade is this Hidden Treasure of the
Eternal City that is capable of harming
the greater will ancient dragons
smithing Stones too are a hidden
treasure of faram Azula capable of
creating weapons that can slay a God so
like so many other things in this video
The dragonkin Almost seem like they are
imitations that were born with a malign
purpose but just like Ronaldo's children
and the first gen albanorics these
imperfect births only led to withered
legs and a pitiful existence
and now we finally arrive at the third
City the nameless Eternal City which is
located deep beneath the Earth tree at
the deep root depths and it's lost its
sky its name and even all traces of the
Knox and I believe we know exactly what
is to blame for all of this Estelle
bastard of the Void is responsible
according to astel's remembrance it is a
malformed star born in the lightless
void far away and with all the force of
a falling meteor it seems Estelle
destroyed an eternal City and took away
their Sky logically this nameless
Eternal City is that Eternal City he
destroyed since it's absolutely
devastated and it is missing its false
night sky and when the description says
astel took away their sky I believe
that's really literal I think Estelle
really did take it away far away because
we don't fight Estelle anywhere near the
nameless Eternal City we fight it way
further south almost as if astel ruined
the nameless City then flowed all the
way down the ancel river to the South
past noxtella and into an enormous
Cavern where it set up a suspiciously
familiar night sky the Eternal Darkness
spell tells us that it's this
manifestation of the despair around the
ruin of the Eternal City and the spell
in question is essentially this black
hole with a powerful gravitational force
drawing everything into it the Estelle
don't seem like these super sentient
beings to me so what if they were mere
animals just drawn towards a sort of
black hole or maybe towards another
powerful gravitational force like a moon
which brings us back to the city of Knox
Stella exploring nostellar's tallest
Towers rewards you with the legendary
Moon of noxtella Talisman a treasure of
theirs that represents the Lost Black
Moon this Moon apparently was once the
guide of countless stars and might have
served as a sort of artificial Moon
below ground
tragically it seems this black moon was
shattered into pieces because fragments
of this Moon can be found in memory
stones which have a really similar
gameplay function to the Talisman
granting you additional memory slots
these stones are rightfully treasured by
Sorcerers and above ground Towers
evoking those of the Eternal City would
be built to protect these precious
artifacts I'm not sure how these
fragments were stolen from the city
though over in nocron there are examples
of foreign forces making incursions into
the city these beings are members of the
company of the Fallen Hawk a company of
slaves that were ordered to explore the
Eternal City logically these soldiers
are slaves of the golden order but who
were the fallen Hawks before their
enslavement
well there's this one little theory that
I quite like by user no contribution 15
on Reddit that suggests that these
Fallen Hawks could have once been common
soldiers of stormvale Castle because
these soldiers once had Hawk Crest
Shields and even a storm Hawk King
dating back to ancient times back when
there was a true storm in stormvale and
so as the theory goes the crest for this
company became that of an inverted Hawk
symbolizing their fall and perhaps
referencing the inverted towers of the
Eternal City that they were doomed to
explore as for why they explore the city
the first thing that comes to mind is
that they might have been sent here to
look for the finguslayer blade which is
the hidden treasure of nokron where the
Fallen Hawks were sent although this is
mostly all just speculation whatever the
case it really helps to characterize
these enemies for you otherwise the only
other observation we can make is that
many of the Fallen Hawks can be found
digging hopelessly in the ground hands
bloodied by their long efforts to this
day torches are an important part of
their design and this reinforces the
idea that they're here looking for
something to the point where the band's
last Embers were used up in their long
search and then they began to burn the
bones of their fellows acquiring the
cold ghost flame and with this new flame
in hand they became dwellers of the
underground for all eternity
like with the Fallen Hawks there are
some really open-ended parts to the
stories of the Eternal cities some
things that are Curiosities to me and I
welcome you to try and answer them for
example the giant Thrones with the giant
knock skeletons on them they're almost a
complete mystery I think the only place
the game references these Thrones are in
the symbols for night sorceries and
bubble sorceries as well beyond that
they're clearly a central part of Knox
culture though we don't know what
purpose these beings had below each one
though you can loot Great Ghost glove
Ward which were given in tribute to
those who died the most glorious of
deaths in the hope of their stories
would become Legend
so it seems the nox not only venerated
these beings with giant Thrones but that
their Spirits as well were considered to
be heroic for their deaths were glorious
another curiosity is the distorted
bodies that are found in the Eternal
cities these erupt from the ground and
many buildings as well of the Knox at
these are the inhabitants of the city
are their deaths related to the Giants
what are these
and finally there are the Gargoyles that
are found in the nameless Eternal cities
with misshapen ruined bodies none of
these gargoyles have been mended but
those that are mended are mended with
black corpse wax and they serve malacath
the Black Blade many of you will
remember that two Valiant gargoyles
defend the path from nokron to the deep
root depths where the nameless Eternal
City is and interestingly it's a coffin
that takes you up there suspended on a
golden script this golden script reminds
me of the description of the cipherpata
which reads the photo of inscription
appears to hang in the air the language
of light spoken by the two fingers it
makes sense that the two fingers would
be aligned with these gargoyles that
serve malacath and maybe some power of
the two fingers is what takes you up to
the nameless Eternal City in this coffin
speaking of coffins there's another
coffin that you ride down from the
ground Cloister to astel's Lair and
there are a ton of coffins found in the
Eternal cities in general Beyond being
some absurd method of Transport perhaps
sending remains along the river was some
sort of burial right
at any rate many of these coffins have
been way laid along the ainsel river
tunnels where ants faced upon the
remains and there's something
fascinating going on with the ants as
well a lot of these have these enormous
abdomens these ants in particular are
based off honey pot ants which
essentially function in nature as these
living sources of food storage for the
colony and the Elden ring variant
dropped one of the most valuable runes
in the lands between they drop a
Newman's Rune which makes a lot of sense
because these ants are feasting upon
corpses and we did speculate earlier
that Newman are indelibly tied to the
Eternal cities I could speculate further
but again I'd welcome your thoughts on
these Curiosities
exploring the lands between in the
modern era it's clear that the Eternal
cities have had this significant
cultural impact upon many things that we
find above ground you can take the
walking mausoleums for example these
have really explicit Eternal City
architecture which is something that you
can't help but notice when you see one
of them wandering down in the nameless
Eternal City these mausoleums it seems
were appropriated from the Eternal
cities to house the remains of soulless
demigods of the golden order something
that suddenly became very necessary to
do after Godwin's death and this tracks
because the Eternal cities do have a bit
of a history with Spirits we mentioned
earlier that they entomb their heroic
Spirits with legendary glove wart but
even the rebirth monuments above ground
that you need to summon Spirits look
kind of like Eternal City constructs so
I speculate that these might have been
pioneered by The Knocks who even if they
didn't use these to summon Spirits they
definitely might have used them to
summon puppets because puppetry is an
invention of the Eternal cities to
create a puppet of someone you need them
to drink a potion made of Starlight
shards which are a prized item that was
once used in the Eternal City as an
ingredient in intoxicating drafts
Starlight shards are used for this
because the Stars command people's Fates
and even the fates of the demigods and
so they can be used in potions given to
create puppets with commanded Fates we
know of two such puppets from the
Eternal City the night maiden and
swordstress puppets who became puppets
of their own volition so Keen were they
it seems to serve the Eternal cities
but when you look at all the puppet
summons that you can get in Elden ring
these two the night maiden and the
swordstress of the Knox these two are a
bit of a special case because most
puppets we find are actually controlled
against their will and are extremely
unwilling to serve their masters an
excellent example of this are the
puppets that are controlled by salivus
or should I say pitia who turn on him
immediately when they're given the
chance these puppets are Knights of the
cuckoo a faction that are explicitly
aligned against carrier and yet these
Knights are forced to fight on karia's
behalf here in Korea all the same
Koreans also seem to have appropriated a
lot of the tools of the Eternal cities
like puppetry and inverted towers as
well which is only natural considering
how much they actually have in common
with the Eternal cities Koreans are
descended from astrologers who also
venerated the night sky another example
of an invention of the Eternal cities
that the Koreans use is found at the
church of vows which features a Knox
statue taken straight out of the Eternal
cities
here at the church Radigan famously
repented his Territorial aggressions and
cleansed himself with Celestial Dew
Celestial Dew is another draft of the
Eternal cities it's called a night tear
which reverses all antagonizations and
moves fate backwards in a sense to a
time or a feeling before those
antagonizations took place
and eventually far away descendants of
the Eternal would finally be found above
ground as well this is in Celia within
caled gowri calls celian's descendants
of the Eternal and in addition to having
one of those signature Thrones at the
center of the city there's also a couple
of Knox bosses here and finally salience
were famed for their Knight class of
sorceries which their assassins made
good use of the celians were also really
proficient at turning invisible which is
an art that the black knives used since
they are after all also Scions of the
Eternal cities and it's just amazing how
it all overlaps in the end
and in the end another group would seek
inroads to knockron this is when we play
the game
these were EG Blythe and Rani Rani is a
character that inherits a lot of the
nox's Legacy she becomes the final
chapter in a story that they started to
tell so so long ago prepare to cry
because I can't wait to cover her story
properly as it deserves but before I go
I want to share a quick word about
audible speaking of people banished to
the underground I actually have the
perfect audiobook to recommend to you
guys today and that's Metro 2033 new
members can try audible free for 30 days
just visit audible.com vati video or
text varti video to 500-500 to get your
free trial started today this is the
story that inspired the video game of
the same name and it reveals this world
where mankind are resigned to the train
tunnels underground after some sort of
nuclear disaster turns the surface into
this radioactive Wasteland Bandits
monsters and other horror leave below
now in the tunnels and listening to this
audiobook will really transport you
there check out this sample it made
archeon shudder to imagine the tunnel
beyond the 700th meter it was horrifying
just to think about it
no one had the guts to go beyond the
700th meter to the north
patrols had made it to the 500th and
having illuminated the boundary post
with the spotlight on the trolley and
convinced themselves that no scum had
crossed it they hastily returned
even the scouts big guys former Marines
would stop at the 680th meter they turn
their burning cigarettes into their
cupped palms and stand stock still
clinging to their night vision
instruments and then they'd slowly
quietly head back without taking their
eyes off the tunnel and never turning
their backs to it
the narrator for this title is really
good and they really nailed the Russian
accents and just the voice acting as
well for your immersion new members can
listen to audible free for 30 days so to
listen to this head to
www.audible.com
video to 500 to 500. thank you to
Audible for sponsoring this video and
thank you for watching